- Alright, good afternoon.
How's everyone doing?
Here we go. That's a good way to start.
So my name is Brendan Grady.
I'm the general manager of
AI and analytics at Qlik.
I am joined today by one
of our amazing customers,
Juan, who will come up and
talk about his use case.
So I was reading the topic
on the way down here,
and I gotta tell you,
that's a pretty scary topic
for a four 30 session, right?
I mean, I hesitate in your history,
but the reality is, is that
if we are hesitating right now
with all of the changes that are going on,
we are gonna be history,
we will be left behind.
So I want to just do a quick
show of hands in the audience.
Who here has more of a technical role?
People that are building
application developers, right?
More business people.
Wow, we're split 50
50. That's pretty good.
So I'll try to tailor the presentation
for both audiences.
So for those of you that
are in the building world,
there's a reality of what you're doing
in supporting your businesses
and your organizations,
and ultimately your businesses
they're all driven by some
type of decision, right?
And that decision can be super
tactical about, you know,
which shirt do I wear today, for example?
Or which sweater do I wear
today? Or maybe even which shoes?
Or it can be super strategic.
Do I buy all of my clothing, for example,
from Neiman Marcus, right?
You can get really big.
So all of those decisions are critical
to the way your organizations perform.
And if you are not basing
this on all of your data,
and using the right techniques,
there is a cost of not knowing.
And I always like to challenge my audience
when I present on this to do a
couple things when you leave,
go Google AI failures.
Some of them are really funny,
some of them are pretty scary.
That's one thing to do.
And then also I give a recommendation
to go look at social media fails.
That's the cost of not knowing.
And there are ways that you
can get it around this, right?
There are ways that you can address this.
And so for those of you that may
or may not be familiar with Qlik,
I wanted to just share
briefly about what we do,
and why it's important
to help you address the
cost of not knowing.
So in a world where I don't
think anybody in the room
would say, we don't
have enough data, right?
Does anybody really feel we
don't have an enough data?
Everyone's struggling with that.
Yeah, good.
You have gotta be able to get access
to all of your data
regardless of where it is.
You need to be able to extract it,
you need to be able to move it around.
You need to be able to make it ready,
and transform it in ways that
people can understand and use.
And I say people,
but the reality is, is moving
forward in the agentic world,
those people may not actually be people,
they may be actually other agents.
So what that means is
you have to be able to
trust that data.
Beyond just trusting that data,
and getting it and getting it ready,
you need to be able to
provide it to people,
or agents that may want to
consume this information
and have trusted data products.
And then in the world
that we're living in,
where analyzing all of your data,
helps you uncover hidden patterns
and make decisions off of
that about, for example,
what color jeans do I want to wear?
I could even use it for that.
But making decisions around
where do I allocate resources?
How much is my forecasting looking like?
You need to be able to bring all of
that data in and analyze it.
But the really interesting thing,
is you wanna make
decisions off of that data
and those decisions can
be extremely strategic,
but they can also be really tactical.
And ultimately you want to
act and do something on it.
Anybody seen here a nice
really pretty visualization
and just say, wow, that's really pretty.
But if you don't do
anything with that data
and Juan, you'll talk about
this when you come up,
that's absolutely critical.
So this is what we do fundamentally.
And there are three things
that we really do well,
like two, three things we really do.
Trusted data products.
We can get all of your data
regardless of where it sits,
and make it available to an
agent or person regardless.
And it's trusted.
So you know that whatever
decisions are being made,
you can have confidence
and we can prove that.
The second thing we do is
we actually find patterns
in that data that you will not find
with a pure visualization vendor.
It is impossible to do.
We have technology that
allows you to do that.
And the third thing that we do uniquely
is how you act on that.
When you combine trusted data products
with the ability to combine this,
you can act on it with more confidence.
We're starting to see in the
world that we grew up in,
for those of you anybody
have BI experience
or reporting experience in the room.
Yeah, right? Our world is
getting rocked here, isn't it?
It is not 2002 where someone
wants a pixel perfect report.
What we are hearing from our customers,
is we are hearing that
they expect their analytics
to become more of an
agentic intelligence layer.
That they built all of this IP,
and now they want to be
able to take advantage
of it in an agentic way.
And if any of you're Qlik customers,
please come by our booth
and we'll help show you
and understand how you can do that.
The second thing we're
seeing in the agentic world,
is data infrastructure.
The data you need to run
an agentic framework.
The data you need to make
decisions in agentic framework,
it is growing at rates that I don't think
any of us expected, even in the back
in the big data days, right?
It is growing way faster than
any of us would've expected.
It needs to be available,
it needs to be fast,
it needs to be performant
and it can't bankrupt you.
So we're starting to see customers
that are really struggling with that.
And then finally, we've been
talking in the BI space,
in the analytics space for 20, 25 years.
It is about what you do with it.
We are starting to see
more and more automation.
That's not a request anymore.
That's in fact a requirement for any of us
that are in this space.
But the challenges remain.
The challenges remain. Trusted data.
I never thought I'd be
standing here in 2025
and saying data quality
initiatives are important,
and are really exciting again.
Customers are struggling with that.
The cost. I talked about
having the data available
where you want.
Adaptability, and being able to do it
in a cost effective manner
remains to be a challenge
for our customers.
And then finally, the
ability to have all of that
information whenever
you need it, rely on it,
so you can act on it and automate
a lot of those decisions.
Customers are still
struggling with all three
of these things and
not just our customers.
Everybody out there that
we speak to is doing that.
I have good news.
I have a customer who's addressed
a lot of these challenges.
And the story that you'll
hear from Ingersoll Rand here
in just a moment,
will be talking about many of these things
that we just talked about,
talk about it in a way
that is not a vendor
telling you how it's going to work,
but the real world example.
And I think the thing that I'm
hoping you'll walk away from
this session today is after
listening to Juan talk,
that if you've invested in
this analytics infrastructure,
this data and analytics infrastructure,
that there is a way forward
for you in this new world.
So I'd love to welcome Juan to the stage
from Ingersoll Rand.
Please come round of applause.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you Brenden.
Alright so for everyone, I
would like to make this real.
I want to mention that
for many, many years,
I've been sitting there
and many of the ideas
that I consider we have
been successful with,
have not been our ideas
is people like, you know,
that have been here, I've
been hearing inspiring,
and I will consider myself like successful
if some of you may say
I'm taking home something
from this presentation.
So let's start with something, right?
Ingersoll Rand is a
manufacturing conglomerate,
multinational, very complex, right?
And if you think about like Ingersoll Rand
is more than 90 brands.
Now, I don't expect you
to know even one single
of these brands, but what
I like about this slide
is that it is not a corporate slide,
it is an IT slide. And you'll see why.
This is an IT slide.
Because if you probably
extend this to your reality,
you'll see behind these dozens of ERPs,
perhaps like 5, 6, 7 CRMs,
supply chain complexities
for every single brand,
decades and decades of legacy systems.
It's all that make us
analytic professionals,
managers, developers,
our life difficult, right?
It is how do we make enterprise
grade, enterprise wide AI,
if we have to deal with that complexity
and data is messy and systems are legacy,
and it's difficult to connect.
It's, look, we have more
than 50 FPs in our company
just to tell you that, right?
So when we have to deal with something
of like that size and
complexity in manufacturing.
Manufacturing data historically, you know,
manufacturing companies are
very data rich, but inside poor.
And that hurts, right?
And we have to deal with
all these complexities.
So when we started to see
all these like AI explosion,
we ask ourselves how can
we attack the AI problem
in our manufacturing reality, right?
Lean teams, small teams of data engineers,
of enterprise wide like analytics.
How can we make AI that
can compete with, you know,
like big muscle high technology companies?
And so the first thing
we did was like, alright,
let's divide the AI problem on one side
of the spectrum, right?
I think you are the left
side on the screen for you.
We said we have workplace
AI, personal use AI right?
Someone needs to push a literacy
and culture program that can
reach 15,000 knowledge workers.
This is your typical Microsoft copilot.
These are the small use
cases where people start
to get a brain muscle on prompting,
on starting to trust AI.
And we started there and
then some ambitions, right?
Let's build some
transformational AI projects,
and we go to the other
side of the spectrum,
enterprise custom AI.
And that's where my team said, hey,
no one in the company
will be able to create
these like complex data pipelines,
structured data, unstructured
data, RAG, vectorization,
let's transform one or two,
or three aspects of the company, sales,
field service technicians,
customer experience.
But we cannot take more than that, right?
Choose, choose one, choose
two, but don't choose 50.
And all the people on the other side,
on one side of the spectrum
started to say, yeah,
here are a hundred use cases,
we want hundred use cases.
What is even more like
difficult at the beginning,
was that the people on the personal use,
or workplace AI, they started
to become good at this.
They started to understand AI
and they started to think, okay,
now I want my small
agent to answer questions
about my salesforce data, my Oracle data,
my JD Edwards data, my SAP
data, my Infor data, right?
And at that point we
analytics team said like,
hold on, hold on, right?
Like that will require a data pipeline,
that will require security,
that will require curated data,
because otherwise this will hallucinate
all over the place.
And so there was a gap
and that gap is users
started to ask for more.
More complex questions,
real time from their data
that assist their daily operations.
And then there's another aspect there
that I didn't talk too much yet,
which is single knowledge domain,
for us it's just fatigue.
So many point solutions,
every vendor trying to monetize their AI,
so much noise or everyone wanted to become
a new data cloud provider,
a new lakehouse architecture, moving data.
For us, it was like a nightmare
just hearing business, hey,
I have this vendor, they're
solving every problem
with AI right?
And that's like the
single knowledge domain.
So we took that gap and we
said, what can we do about this?
So we came with this.
I mean this is probably
not obvious for some,
some may be saying we already do this,
but if not, this is going
to make a lot of sense.
And let's put in that gap
something called data platform AI,
internal name for this.
And let's think about our
medallion architecture, right?
We have our lakehouse
architecture with our bronze,
and silver and gold zone.
But where is our most
curated data in the company?
It is on that data platform.
It is on Qlik in our case,
that is working as that glue logic,
almost like connective tissue
where for years and years,
our analytics professionals,
analytics community,
data citizens, have been
putting lot of effort, time,
sweat, blood, on curating databases,
creating pipelines that were sustaining
traditional analytics.
And what we said is, okay,
that's our new Goldilocks zone.
If we can enable AI directly
on all these thousands of analytics assets
that have been created with
time that some of these
we are still depreciating, right?
Is going to be like pervasive AI
with all the complexity of custom AI,
but at a scale, right? Reuse the assets.
And so that's where we partner with Qlik
on working on the private
preview on Qlik answers,
and understanding like, how
can we make this a reality
because we are betting big on this, right?
Is all these assets on the platform
becoming conversational analytics,
and even better, our
data citizens community
is upskill to AI developers
at almost zero cost, right?
Where that's something that, you know,
getting talent out there is
right now like very difficult,
very expensive and so on.
So, of course we need to present
an reference architecture,
because probably the technical
people won't be happy
if we don't present
something that they say, hey,
this makes sense, this doesn't make sense.
It looks similar to us,
but this is what we are building, right?
We have data sources, we
have extraction layers
that are moving the data near real time.
Again the 80, 90 ERP systems, CRM systems,
we have our medallion architecture,
but then we start to see some AI factory
that can scale, can be replicated,
can create an economy of a
scale, is not going to create
an agentic nightmare of
recreating the wheel every time.
And that's where we start to put the MCPs
on our most curated data,
which are very granular by the way.
And that's really cool
because when we have
front facing application
that needs data from the
procurement data in Qlik,
or from the supply chain data,
or from the order management
data, if something changes,
we only need to go and modify
the order management data
and that's it.
And the MCP will make that data available
to whatever downstream
applications are using that
without us having to modify
like a humongous AI agent.
So this is creating like a very resilient,
reliable mesh of agents out of the box
because we are relying
now on data platform AI.
And so the use cases are there.
For us 20,000 hours saved on
account managers being able to
put, a year like 20,000 hours
more of like customer facing time
because they don't have to go
and find this information somewhere else.
Or their management teams in Asia Pacific
that had to deal before
with 5, 6, 7 CRMs or ERPs
to sell something now are
coming to a single dashboard
that makes all that complexity agnostic,
and asking simple questions like
what are my top 10 orders
that are going to miss
a shipping date if I don't
remove a hold, right,
in the next five days.
And that's starting to
change and the way we work,
and it's almost out of the gate, right?
So this is, you know,
like if someone is fan of
some of those garner presentations,
is the first time that
we finally could say
we are delivering on that
old promise of combining
all these descriptive, diagnostic,
predictive, prescriptive,
and perceptive analytics,
because in a single place,
because of these data platform AI process
supported and enabled by
platform like Qlik right?
So to end the presentation,
couple of tactical unconventional hacks.
The first one is again, well
everything I just mentioned,
the analytics platform is
your closest to AI ready data.
Use it, right?
You have invested,
again, like a lot of time
curating your finance, your FP,
and your procurement, your supply chain,
your demand generation,
your operations data.
Now you have like the
possibility to just plug AI
on top of that and make
AI pervasive across
your entire user base of analytics users.
Second one is your analytics super users
become your instant AI army.
This is really important.
Like, doesn't matter how
much you think about it,
you have been building a
community of data citizens
and professionals and
they will love to jump
into the AI wagon,
and this is giving them the opportunity.
Immediately you're telling them, look,
your skills are completely up to date.
The data you have curated,
the data, you know,
is now the fuel of agentic AI and MCPs.
And you own that, and that's empowerment,
and that creates like
an amazing engagement,
and opportunity for, you
know, superpower analytic
professionals in the
company with the, you know,
the hype of AI which is very real, right?
So with that, I will hand
over back to Brendan,
and thank you for your time.
(audience applauding)
- [Brenden] Is that on? There we go.
A couple takeaways from Juan's section,
that I think are really important
and I mentioned it in my first part,
is if you've invested in a
data and analytics layer,
all is not lost, right?
We started off with a
little fear of, you know,
after your history, the
reality of what you're hearing
from a company like Ingersoll Rand
where I knew you had a lot of ERPs,
I didn't know you had that many ERPs.
They have built this
amazing infrastructure
on data and analytics that
they are just going to
take to the next level already,
by opening up a few new capabilities.
Like MCP is a big move
forward for you, right?
And that investment is
there for them already.
That's number one.
Number two, and I don't
think you could have
said it any better, as a
former BI developer myself,
I ask myself the questions,
what is my role in this?
Our role, those of us that have
built analytic applications
over time, our role in it is
to become to, as you said,
become the AI army, right?
That's the core thing.
So as you think about
why is Ingersoll Rand
able to take advantage of this?
There are a couple pieces of the puzzle
that Qlik has delivered.
We're not their entire infrastructure.
We're not trying to be
their entire infrastructure.
We're trying to address
very specific problems
for companies like Ingersoll Rand.
The first one is giving
them trusted data products,
and the way they've built
their analytics applications,
those analytics applications,
they're the basis for
everything they're gonna do
with agentic AI because it's trusted,
and I love the Goldilocks layer.
That's a new expression
that I learned today,
but the Goldilocks layer, it's just right,
and it's really amazing.
So getting that trusted
data products in place,
we help them do that
with the data pipelines,
as Juan mentioned,
they can make changes
in their source systems,
but because of the way that we
help them manage their data,
they're able to know that
the downstream systems
and the downstream decisions
and actions were accurate.
So that's one thing.
The second thing that
we're able to help with,
and we really fit in is
our analytics engine.
That is the secret sauce for Qlik.
90 source systems sounds like a lot,
and I'm only touching on
how many source systems
you truly have.
The 90 ERP, this is where
our analytics engine
comes in extremely strong.
We are able to help
you bring data together
in a fashion that will
reduce the amount of time
of building your data model
somewhere between 80 and 90%.
It will cut down that time.
And then what you have,
is you have your trusted
data foundation for AI.
And then finally we are
building all of this
on top of an agentic framework.
For those of you that raised your hands
of being in the analytics and BI space,
this is the future, right?
The future unfortunately
started about a year ago
for all of us and we have
to catch up with that.
So we are really looking
at the existing set
of capabilities we've
brought to the market
to support extremely complex scenarios
like Juan spoke about.
And we're building it on
top of an agentic framework.
And the way we're really
thinking about it is,
Qlik wants to be a
portfolio of capabilities,
that will help you understand the context
of the information you
have in all of this data.
We are going down a path
where we're bringing
assistance to you and or we
are integrating with things
like anthropic.
We're integrating things like copilot.
We're integrating with
capabilities out there
that will allow you to
interact with the secret sauce,
the analytics engine,
plus the trusted data products
in a way that will be natural language,
that your users will
feel comfortable with.
And that ultimately will help you target
very specific business challenges.
These assistants are designed
to tap into our agentic framework,
and have very specific tasks.
You'll notice here that
we're focused on data tasks,
or analytics tasks.
You're not gonna see us build an agent
around customer service.
That's not our expertise,
Juan, you know that,
our expertise is data and analytics.
So we are focusing on
bringing agents out there
that can work with MCP
that you can interact with.
And then also we are going down the agent
to agent architecture approach.
So agents from other
systems, as Juan pointed out,
can interact with, say for
example, a data quality agent.
Hey, I'm trying to make a
decision around my supply chain
to build my shoes, my socks and my suits.
Go tell me whether or not
my data quality is correct,
and the agent will go off and do that.
We're also focusing on knowledge agents.
And knowledge agents are really designed
to help you bring that unstructured data,
which for the record is
about 85% of the data
in your organization.
Bring all of that into
a knowledge assistant
that will allow you to make decisions
off of that data without needing to build
your own RAG pipelines.
We can cut that time down by 90%.
And if you want to talk about
the experience that Juan
and team have had with Qlik answers,
I encourage you to talk about
the time it can save them.
Ultimately these agents
are designed to help
remove some of the manual tasks
and help you make more effective decisions
based off of this trusted architecture.
So regardless of what you're using,
whether it's a Microsoft,
whether you're using some of
the AWS amazing announcements
we've heard over the past couple of days,
anthropic, whatever it may be,
you can interact with MCP
and as you go down your agent framework,
we are designed to work with other
agentic frameworks as well.
We're also trying to build this
on top of an infrastructure
that is going to help
you be adaptive, right?
We've seen data gravity,
data gravity is going to be a challenge.
Wouldn't we all love to put
our data in one single location
and just have it sit there and be happy.
Juan, you would be super
happy if we could do that.
The reality of everything
you're dealing with
is that you need a set of capabilities
or portfolio of capabilities
that are adaptable
to the way you want to work.
You can have some of your
data that sits over on Azure,
or AWS, you can have it sit in Google,
you can have it sit in a
Databricks or Snowflake,
all of these locations.
And we have gone down
an open lakehouse path
with Iceberg that will help you make sure
that you can take advantage
of your data wherever it is.
Make sure you're adaptable.
You can do it in a scalable way.
The number that I've heard on scalability
on our Iceberg instance,
it was really interesting.
I heard 17 million transactions per second
is what we are able to bring
through our Iceberg instance.
So if you think about
that type of scalability,
I think about the supply chains
that you have to deal with,
that type of scalability is incredible.
And we do it so we can help
you reduce your data ingress
and egress charges with Iceberg.
So we're helping you be adaptable,
we're helping you save money,
and we're trying to make
sure you're doing it
with trusted data infrastructure.
Look, has everybody seen
the, the MIT study out there
that's only 5% of AI.
Yeah, super. Really, really fun isn't it?
5% of AI initiatives have failed.
Our approach at Qlik and what
I'm hoping you saw from Juan,
and we'll open it up to
questions in a second here,
he is a real example
about how to be successful
with an initiative like this, right?
Juan is one of the 5%.
Our goal is to make sure that we can make
that number not 5% successful,
we can make almost every
customer successful.
We really want to do that.
So a couple things that
you need to think about,
what we've spoke about today.
And as Juan pointed out, yes,
we all love our architecture diagrams.
We all do, right?
It really lays it out for us.
But the reality of the situation is,
you have to make sure
that you have context
as you go down this
agentic framework, right?
Making decisions with all your data,
on top of a trusted data foundation,
and doing it in a way
that allows you to adapt
to where your data resides,
is going to be absolutely critical.
If you are not going down that path,
and thinking about decisions in context,
your initiative is likely to fail.
You will end up being one
of those Google searches
that I just spoke about.
So really think about context
in the framework of agentic AI.
The second thing, governance.
I mean governance has
become even more important.
Governance ultimately comes down to,
what we've seen is that,
feedback into these models is critical.
One of the things that
we've noticed with customers
that have been successful in deploying
our unstructured data assistant already,
is that they give constant
feedback into their models,
and they give constant feedback
with trusted information
and they govern that information.
It allows them to ensure
that whatever answers
they are they're getting
and whatever decisions they're making,
that it has been through
a feedback mechanism.
And I am blatantly and
shamelessly stealing the AI army
concept here because you've
gotta let that AI army
be those people that help
you govern that data,
govern those models and
help govern your decisions.
Those of us in the BI and analytics space,
we're the experts in that data.
We know it, right?
So it's one of those things
that you can really do.
The other thing is,
and I'm gonna make a fairly
controversial statement here,
as an analytics vendor,
who has made their career
on building dashboards.
That world is gone.
It is not the world that we grew up in.
Analytics as a destination, as a portal,
is no longer going to be acceptable.
And if you go back to Juan's markitecture
and architecture diagram,
I loved across the top,
you literally have every generative AI
and agentic tool across the top there.
That's the world we're living in now.
Everything that we do
from a data and analytics
and decision making process,
has got to be embedded within
your business processes.
We're at a point where the digital natives
are entering the workforce
and our successful customers
are really focusing on
helping this workforce
who grew up with mobile phones, iPads,
and asking Siri to make them breakfast.
That's the world we're living
in, in this generative AI.
So as you think about that,
really ensure that you're
going to embed everything
into your workflows.
Ultimately, Juan, I would
imagine you probably
consider it success
almost if they don't know
they're using your AI capabilities,
'cause if they know, that means
there was an outage, right?
That's usually the bad news.
But you want to make it embedded.
Your supply chain
manager should just think
they're running their supply chain.
Your marketing operations
lead should just think
they're optimizing their campaign.
Analytics is going to
become part of an AI,
is going to become part
of everything we do.
So consider that.
And then finally, these
three things combined,
will help make sure
that you have the right
enterprise approach in
having the enterprise
grade AI strategy that will
allow you to get there.
What I really want you
to walk away from is not
necessarily what we at Qlik have to say,
but really listen to Juan's story, right?
He has an amazing foundation.
He has amazing organization
that backs him up on this,
and the proof is in the pudding.
I actually did a little research
on some of the business
results for Ingersoll Rand.
Just encourage you to go look
at their business results,
because the results that they're seeing,
is the results of what we
just talked about here today.
I actually wanted to end
this in about 30 minutes.
I know it was for an hour.
I wanted to give some time to see
if there are any
questions for Juan and me.
Juan, I'd love to bring you back up.
Thank you.